today's episode is brought to you by
grey block pizza
1811 pico boulevard on the way to the
beach in los angeles
gray block get that hitter
and they used to have a big girl bust
they called her clutch
that's what they call her because she
was uh
conceived in a um
standard vehicle you know
so that's how that works baby
um good to be here man i'm just an
egomaniac with an
inferiority complex
and i'm just trying to come up who is it
come on this is the come up with
eddie 9 v
[Music]
well i just broke up with my baby
well i just moved up to lucky street
when the mayor
came and said to me here on the karma
come on
you wanna come up baby come on
and explain to see between you and me we
got so
much love and in chemistry it's gonna
come
well good things keep on coming and
there ain't going to be there you go
good things that keep on coming and i
ain't
gonna keep on running i'm on the come up
and that is eddie 9v they call them
eddie 9v and people look at eddie and
they say well damn man
and that's eddie 9v
good to be here man i'm alive you're
alive and uh what's going on
it is hell it's mar it's the end of
march
it's 2021
and a lot of people didn't think this
was gonna happen
and i'm not naming names but
mayans dude so if you know any mayans
out there maya
who they got maya rudolph mayan angelo
um um
[Music]
there's a couple of mayans out there
still remaining and they don't believe
in the calendar so
must be nice must be nice mayans
to just somebody invite you over and you
say uh well
yeah i don't believe in you know oh
friday doesn't exist so i'm not going to
be there
or somebody says hey come to my birthday
party and they say hey well you know
the world ended 11 years ago so i'm not
bringing a present
you know that's the most mayan [ __ ] ever
brothers that's so
mayan how is that not a tv show
that's so mayan and we can actually get
to the bottom of what these mayans were
saying
because the mayans i mean whatever
i don't want to give them any more
credit but you know what they did
they sold us short that's what they did
uh that song again
was called the come up with brighter
days
by eddie 9v and that's a nice tune right
there
and you know um what's going on what's
going on in your world we got a nice
episode for you today
i want to continue to suggest to people
that they send in unique videos and
things that they want us to discuss on
here
uh also on theovan.com is where you can
upload the video
or you can email it to tpwproducer
at gmail or googlemail.com
right there so um
what's happening well i'm in the uh
original studio baby let's go
so if you need me i'm right here knock
knock who's there
moi baby french me daddy
cause i'm he i look i'm i'm you know
i'm multi you don't have to be in one
place anymore
when i was young you had to be in one
place
if you wanted to you know if you wanted
to talk to a man who sold matches you
had to go he was only at the match shop
or if you wanted to um see a man about a
you know a cantaloupe or a horse or
anything if you wanted to talk to a uh
you know somebody that sold belts you
know or outdoor equipment yard seating
then you needed to go to a specific spot
and meet him
but now
people can be anywhere you see how i
just did that
i'm in three spots daddy i'm in three
spots right there if you're looking on
the video
um yeah nice to be here i did some
comedy last night
got up out there at um
at uh they had a place over in los
angeles it's like between two buildings
and it's
you can hear people you can hear
i'll be honest you can hear gay dudes
swallowing pills right on the other side
of the fence i mean it's uh
you know there's a lot of that kind of
activity you know outdoor
barbiturate use and a lot of men
trying to say they're just buddies but
they're also
you know one of them as a condom in his
sock so
you know what they call they used to
call it christmas friends
when i was growing up they would refer
if they if they had men
when i was growing up they didn't have
probably maybe 70 or 80 gay men
you know overall okay
and so you know you didn't there wasn't
a lot of
now there's a thousands you know you
have gay you have gay pride parade you
have
you know gay uh you know you have bath
houses you have
um what do you have you have uh
kathy griffin you have all of the
you know everything you could want you
got um
[Music]
you know you got little you know sex
toys and stuff where you could also do a
little bit of coke off the end of it you
know they got everything that
you know they got man you know every
you know they got swing sets that uh
vibrate they got everything you could
want for gay culture
now but when i was young they didn't
have that
and sometimes you would see men
being with other men and they called it
christmas friends oh that's
those guys are christmas friends
or they would say oh them boys is uh
you know um they said there's oh those
boys are brothers
you know they tried to trick you if you
were a kid
and they didn't want you knowing that
gay existed
because that was kind of the time i grew
up in they didn't want everybody knowing
that gay was a
an option there was it was still kind of
under wraps it was
kind of covert you know it was like um
you could it was it was available but it
wasn't readily available
it was like these top shot nba
basketball cards you gotta
if you're not on the website at a
certain time you're not you're not gonna
get it
and that's kind of how it was with gay
back then
you know it just wasn't readily
available so every now and then you see
men and they and your
your parents would say oh those those
guys are those those guys are unique
brothers
or those guys are cousins you know and
you'd be like well they're cousins
that's
why are they you know wrestling and kind
of kissing in that
you know in the front of that [ __ ] in
the front of that um
pontiac and nobody had a lot of answers
for you but
anyway that is the come up by eddie 9v
and um what's going on in my life man oh
yeah i got into a new home
and it's kind of like i never
you know i went out of town so i i you
know i'm back here in los angeles for a
week and so i'm like
whoa i literally was leaving the house
and i was like well who
takes care of the house while i'm gone
you know who why like is is everything
okay i literally looked
i was like hey you guys gonna be okay
and i'm just like talking to the
furniture i just
it was kind of just i don't know i
didn't think about
who was taking care of the home
while because i never owned it
so now i'm just like okay every you know
i'll open up the cupboard i'm like all
right you guys be good you know
and it's just like a little spice rack
in there or
you know some thyme and some um
uh what else they had in there cinnamon
so um but that's been kind of
interesting just kind of feeling that
out you know
uh can't decide if i want a hat on or
off you know
you ever feel like that
i get like that sometimes
you know a hat is just a little
apartment for your head really
and that is uh that's legitimate
what's going on yeah a lot of neat stuff
yeah so if you have some cool stuff
sending in
um we're gonna get into some things on
this episode
uh what's happening
what's happening kind of like what
happened this past we kind of did some
comedy sets
over there that's what i was telling you
about i did some comedy sets over there
in
uh in los angeles
and they had uh
you know it i don't know i got an
argument with this one not an argument
but like
a confrontational moment kind of i guess
um with this one female comedian and she
uh i don't know i've never seen this
woman
seem like she know has ever had an ounce
of joy
in her being but um
anyway uh she got on me like i didn't
have a mask on
i don't know mascot and here's why
because nobody has them on anymore
that's what i'm saying and i'm not i've
now spent time in nashville i spend time
in los angeles
i don't see them anymore
people don't gots dumb
and so that's like well you know so she
gets on me and she's like kind of like
oh you don't think
we should be wearing masks you know and
i'm like i just
you know nobody has meanwhile
there is a i don't want to say homeless
guy but a guy who
duh you know this dude is not
this guy hasn't been in a laundry room i
bet in probably a year and a half
and he's defecating bro
you know what i'm saying making freaking
body rope dog you feel me
you know what i'm saying serving that
booty isthmus you know what i'm saying
bro
this dude is making them freaking dirty
florida's just rolling out of his boot
and so i uh like nine feet away from us
and this lady's giving me a hard time
so but i stood my ground baby and let my
yappers
shine um
so that was it was a little conversation
it was kind of exciting though
it's kind of exciting um
[Music]
i got to be in a tesla i got to be in a
tesla
and that was interesting because
i'd never been in there
and it's real
quiet i almost felt like a snail like a
snail like if you're in his little cage
or whatever
um
you know or his butt i don't know what
is that thing a snail has his butt
oh i never even thought about that
that a snail is just just you know he's
just scooting around with his big
butt behind him really with them apple
bottom jeans
baby and he scoots with the freaking
fur bruh the um snail's got that
freaking
peach on him boo boo you know it he's
got that booty
oh so anyway i got to be in a tesla that
was interesting it yeah it doesn't
feel i like i like
i like a little gasoline beneath me
i like knowing that if somebody
mishandles a cigarette in the vehicle we
could all die
you know call me old-fashioned that's i
like that
i just like something about it a little
bit
i like when you get in a real classic
vehicle
and a classic vehicle is
you know that's a it's something people
are basically hoping that
if their grandpa dies he gonna give them
that's what it is and
some of those when you put gasoline in
them
it's like you sit in there that thing my
god i mean you could feel the lord just
it feels like the whole yeah
you sit it feels like the lord's jerking
you off you know
trying to bust you out at a just a dna
level
just really trying to just get you to
skeet right out of your damn spine baby
you know what i'm saying
um so
yeah so that was it it was it was
interesting to leave
um a house it's just interesting to have
a home
it's kind of scary i guess
i've always kind of thought of myself i
think is kind of transient a little bit
you know and i kind of like being a
little bit transient i like having the
ability to
go
and to come you know what i'm saying boy
just joking guys jesus man
take care of yourself man um
[Music]
but no i realize that about i like my i
like always having the ability to just
kind of scoot off if i want to
you know less hooks in the uh in the
fish
and i realized that about myself even
when it comes to anything i always i
like having one foot out the door
i'll be eating at the dinner table but
i'll be damned
if i don't have one of my legs all the
way out the door
or at least hanging out the window or
something i'll at least leave my shoes
over there
because i got one foot out the door it's
just the way i've always been kind of
you know i think i just don't want to
feel connect
i think sometimes that i don't want to
feel connected man
i want to but
man
you know it's scary how much connection
can
uh how debilitating it can almost be
how
yeah i mean it's a vulnerable thing just
showing your glue to somebody just
saying hey here's the sticky parts of
who i am does this work for you
um does this work for this
um yeah
it's interesting man it's really
interesting uh
having something that has a is a form of
commitment for me
is uh is interesting so
uh we got a good a good a good episode i
feel like
and i want to thank uh nick davis a
producer and
um sean uh dugan of it and riley mao
and um colin reiner and everybody who
helps take care of this program so what
we got here
is i'm having a little bit of that
liquid death baby i didn't know water
could be
i'll be honest with you i didn't know
water could have as much damn
water in it this water has the most
water
per water that i've ever seen man
or been around um we had a lot of people
that submitted
you know we had a young fellow last week
that called in he couldn't decide
a senior quote to leave into his uh
yearbook
and yearbook man i hope have they
discontinued yearbooks i wonder that
i hope not because
yearbooks was that it was that end of
the year
thing it was the last chance
for you to say what you wanted to say
to that person
hey jennifer i hope you have a great
summer you got nice
legs you could say and
sign it and then here's the thing you
would close it and give it back to them
so they didn't know immediately where
you signed it
it was almost like a time capsule for
guys who were afraid to say something to
a girl
and now you had all summer you had all
summer to wonder
all dang does jennifer
know
how i feel about her limbs
it was just different it was a different
time
or you'd write oh tiandra good luck with
the
baby you could write stuff like that
because where i'm from these girls got
embryoed up baby
you know these things man
i don't know if you've ever been to
embry riddle university but there was no
this was no laughing matter bro these
gals got
embryoed up boy
[ __ ] better have my zygote
they was yelled out baby these girls
um i never will forget i lost a spelling
bee in fifth grade to a pregnant girl
god bless her helena was her name
named after her grandmother who was also
helena
and uh beautiful girl not really
beautiful but
nice girl with a baby so
you know when i had all you know i had
all these things that she was
cheating or she had a baby in her it's
you know she's running on
you know because god puts an extra
little batch of effort in you when you
got a baby in you
you got a little brain powder flowing in
your veins because it's but you got to
make a brain
so over the first couple months you got
little pieces of brain rolling through
your body like
tetris and then they meet up in there in
the baby's head
so i'm thinking oh this lucky broad the
spelling bee came right along
you know when she was just kind of uh
zigging that goat you know what i'm
saying
in that first trimester dog so
i'm thinking every now and then they
would ask her to spell this or spell
that
spell rattlesnake you know spell shiffer
robe
spell panty and right where she was
thinking that a little piece of that
baby brain would get you know
lodged in the back of her you know
throat
and that would help her uh get the word
right
and i lost i i lost on inconvenience i
remember losing on
but it was a good time man it was the
goodest of times and it was the worst of
times
uh we got some senior quotes that came
in and so i want to get to some of those
um i want to thank everybody for hitting
the hotline 985-664-9503
people had recommendations uh for senior
quotes
all right i want to say originally we
got this call from a man right here
and we're this this fellow named zachary
and let's get this call uh
so you can remember it he needed a
little help
you know what's up this is zachary from
illinois i'm a senior in high school
this year
and i'm in desperate need of a senior
quote and i thought who better to give
me a senior quote than the theo vaughn
so if you give me a funny one-liner
there you go
and there's zachary right there who
can't think of a sentence for himself
and that's you know that's a male
problem
you got that sentence impotence dog and
look i've been halfway through a
sentence and i can't get it all the way
up
i'll be honest you know some of you just
like hey i love to
and you can't get it out or why don't we
or oh man i want to
and that happens actuary but we got some
great submissions people really wanted
to uh
to offer some support for you zach so
let's get a few right here here we go
this is uh from your boy pat right here
let's hear it from white pat
what's up theo and team it's pat from
colorado i got a
suggestion for our boys senior quote
issue
theo i think you'll get behind this one
a little bit business in the front
party in the back four years at this
school and i didn't learn jack
gang gang there you go brother
and i remember doing uh mushrooms one
time at school
and i remember thinking my shirt was a
snake
because i'd worn a felt made shirt made
out of pool table felt they had a guy in
our town for a while
his wife had died and uh
and so he he was doing uh making shirts
out of felt at a pool table
you know they had a bad batch of pool
tables in this town next to us called
bogalusa louisiana
someone had made pool tables and the
wood that they used had termites in it
and beautiful tables but they were
disappearing
you know you could barely get halfway
through a game of damn nine ball and
uh one of the legs be missing off of the
thing
you know and now you want one of the
pockets is uphill suddenly
so uh this fella in our town got the
felt off of the tables that green fella
made shirts out of them beautiful
shirts and he marketed it as christmas
apparel
and um and so i got one man
you know i was lucky enough to cop one
of them there's only probably about 11
or 15
of them and i got one and i remember
eating mushrooms and wearing it at
school when i thought my arm was a snake
and that's one of the side effects of
eating uh
psilocybic mushrooms it'll snake your
arm out
you know what i'm saying you'll be
sitting there in class and next thing
you know
your arm is eating a white mouth and
you're like damn okay
okay we are we getting vibey today
okay today the science lesson is in my
brain
so i'm you know geeked up and uh so i
excuse myself from the classroom and i
tried to excuse myself from
my arms but you can't do that
so i went into the uh bathroom and i
stayed in there for about four hours at
school
in the bathroom and because i could
things were a little more manageable in
there
you know you could pee or you could do
the sink
or you could you know you got to meet
everybody if there were kids you didn't
know everybody has to bathroom
and so that was the beauty of being in
there was you got to meet people you
didn't know
but um the weird part was when you'd be
in there and they'd come back to urinate
for the second time
because on average people would urinate
probably two and a half times during the
day three times
and uh so when you saw some guys for the
second time they would that was a little
weird
because it's easy to kind of understand
why somebody's in the bathroom one time
it's harder to understand
why they're still in the bathroom hours
later when you go back in
and they're still in there just doing
toilet sink sink sink toilet
sink so but that was high school man
but that's a great senior quote right
there thank you very much little pat
colorado pat dog that mountain
cat pat onward let's hear another one
that came in right here out of someone
hey theo what up it's steve out here in
black mountain north carolina
what's up steve out of black mountain
and um
and i'll be honest you don't see a lot
of blacks in the mountains dude that's
really
you know a lot of black people i feel
like are more
sea level you know prefer sea level or
we're just above sea level
sea level is also can be i think
dangerous for more african americans but
um anyway brother thank you very much
for calling in man
gang i have a senior quote submission
for you
everybody wants to contribute
however nobody wants to be contributed
to
therefore the greatest gift you can give
someone is to let them
contribute to you peace
yeah that's a good one man that's a real
thinker right there stevie
and i appreciate you yeah and look i can
relate to that i want to be
i'm terminally unique i want to be any
way i
i want to be unique to a fault where it
even at my own detriment sometimes i
want to be
it has to be my it has to be unique
to my own detriment um
[Music]
yeah it's hard to be want to be
contributed to to just accept people's
contributions especially if you're used
to handling things yourself
uh and that's a nice gift is to let
somebody do something for you
you know let somebody love you let
somebody uh hug you
look you know let somebody have your
last caramel baby your last uh
butterscotch daddy
thank you steve that's another great one
you have right there zachary
onward here we go
what up theo this is bonjour uh
maybe i'm coming from croatia too so
what's up bonjour out of croatia
and that's croatia for you though you
can name somebody anything baby
it's ba i mean it's the damn white
detroit bro
you could name somebody tickle me out my
dog
you know what i'm saying you can name
somebody sturgeon
i mean you could name somebody damn uh
uh motor cross
you'll meet a fellow named motocross
over there by the ocean by that slovak
uh area onward this is the wrong
approach but i remember i always used to
sign this on people's yearbook as a
quote
uh i just signed your crack now let's
smoke some
i don't know there's my quote thank you
for letting me say that
uh and i love your show theo you're the
man
thank you bonjour and i'm glad you're
letting you guys make videotape over
there and uh
in croatia baby and you'd be good over
there and you guys
keep doing whatever you got to do baby
to stay alive baby
all right and that is a good quote yeah
if you got a smoke crack i never got to
smoke crack
you know when a lot of people know that
you know i never got to smoke crack in
my life and i've thought about
sometimes i think about you know not
being sober just so i could go smoke it
not crazy but you know we really should
have somebody who is a crackhead or
addicted to crack for a long time on
here
to talk about that and i would love to
have mike lindell the mic
the my pillow guy you know people don't
know that he was a crack addict
and nothing will uh nobody nobody needs
sleep more than someone who's been on
crack for a few days and so i'm not
shocked really that the man
came out with that uh that head rest
baby
you know what i'm saying that [ __ ]
synthetic goose baby
that rest peace that pillar dog praise
god baby let's hear another one here we
go
onward yo what's up brad king it's uh
dylan from mobile alabama
what's up dylan from mobile
and mobile is a good place to uh
to kind of drink coffee and kind of wish
you were maybe somewhere else let's hear
more
you know that poor city hitter but uh
i think a nice senior quote would be uh
one of the teachers is having an affair
with students or something like that
you know stir up some [ __ ] before you
leave dude yeah
hey man but uh
shout out to you bro uh [ __ ] funniest
dude in the game
hope you come back down here man i know
he's in biloxi for the dark arts tour
hopefully you come back bro love you
gang gang
gang bro thanks dylan man and yeah i
love uh i got a
uh a sep's stepsister
named holly that lives over there in
spanish fort alabama
and um i guess i don't know what it is i
think they had
i don't know why spanish ford is what it
is i don't know enough about it but
mobile is getting better the beaches
they're really starting they're doing
all they can to really beach it out
um you know you'll see like a
it's a it's a place you can kind of find
a [ __ ] you could find barbecue
near a palm tree mobile's that weird
it's a weird little uh
it's kind of like a transgender type of
um
uh like land like you know it's beach
but it's
country but it's sandy but it's um
tropical um
there's like cannon balls like you could
like you know
there's a lot of like vague civil war
gift shops but
you're not really sure what it's for and
they'll have like a seashell in it just
a lot of stuff that doesn't
you know it's a it's a hodgepodge if you
will
um but if you get lost downtown it's
nice
and i got lost down there and i was
really surprised at how nice it was one
time
but thank you for calling in dylan and
that's another great uh great quote
right there
leave by starting something you know
say just be straight up man mr herbert
ass touched me once
say that
you know say uh scotty used to bang miss
uh randolph
say you know what i'm saying like yeah
leave a little bit of uh
leave the light on for people hit them
with that [ __ ] motel six in their
crotch you know
say hey miss uh
jerifula
was fine as hell baby okay you know what
i'm saying do a little something i like
your attitude
start a little something you know
say hey i hid 200 dollars in mr vliet's
honda civic
gang let's go
uh we got one more that came in for you
let's hear it
what up rat king this is brian
calling from california california brian
in california man it's a good place for
somebody to uh
get angry at you about not having a mask
on while a homeless fella
gives birth to them freaking but you
know them rear body babies dog
only six or seven feet away from you
praise god let's hear more brian
cisco bay area uh i was calling
because you were asking about a high
school senior quote
and a couple came to mind when i was
listening
the first one is from the louisiana bad
boy
the rat king mr theo vaughan think it's
words to live by
right in there be good to yourself you
probably deserve it
amen if i could go back write those
words
it's much better than whatever i wrote
something stupid that
i thought was funny at the time but you
live by those words and i honestly think
that that's gonna make you happier now
the other quote
probably not school and that's true man
you know it's so funny how many guys i
i'll run into and
and and women occasionally but mostly
men and
and will just share that back to me say
be good yourself
you know be good to yourself it's hard
isn't it
it's hard brian it's hard to be good to
ourselves
um
and i don't know if it's because we
spend so much time around ourselves i
don't know if it's
that you got to be tougher on who you
you know
but it's hard it's hard man so thank you
for that well
that well wish baby now let's uh let's
hear the other one
that that's going to make you happier
now the other quote
probably not school appropriate but it
was the clip you played after
the high school senior called in and
some elderly woman was screaming at
somebody
and she said if i want to [ __ ] i can
[ __ ]
it ain't nobody business but mine
if your school will let you print it
also
good words to live by but that's it man
i hope
i hope this senior can find something
good i would go with the rat king
and uh i hope you be good to yourself
man
you deserve it gang brother thanks brian
i like that second one man i'm gonna
play yours again
if i want to [ __ ] i can [ __ ]
that ain't nobody business but mine yeah
there you go
baby there you go
and we should start a senior yearbook
for actual seniors
that's what it should be somebody should
just make a yearbook
of all the old people in their town and
say this is our senior yearbook
and you go around and get them to sign
it now
you know what i'm saying people be
writing real stuff
you know that would be amazing just to
get you know
to really get uh to just really just
to capture that last hurrah
and then you compare it or maybe like
our high schools should come back years
later and get a quote later on
you know that's what they should do
but those are great man those are really
nice suggestions for zach
and i think that um the good thing also
is
that uh we have a montage of other ones
that came in and we'll put that on at
the end of the episode so you guys can
check that out and
and thank you for being a part of this
past weekend and a part of um
a part of our lives here i want to thank
you for that i also want to tell you
right now
about the zebra and about insurance or
insurance
look i got it i got into a home recently
and i was like damn i gotta what if
everything burns down
you know if you're in an apartment or
you're renting you don't care if
something burns down like who gives a
[ __ ] you probably started the fire
hell a lot of times i'm shocked [ __ ]
didn't burn down
but now every time i leave home i need
to head back home
you know to make sure that the oven
isn't on or
that that you know didn't leave the
heater on there's all the some there's
too many things that could happen
i just worry like is is everything going
to be ok
well who can help you now is the zebra
the nation's leading insurance
comparison site for car and home
insurance man
for car and home where are you at
usually in your car
in your home don't just live willy-nilly
live insured
they can help you save money today when
you use the
zebra.com insurance finally feels
like it's in black and white that zebra
baby
no more confusion you can secure your
insurance from the zebra.com
or over the phone from one of their
licensed insurance agents
how much money can you save on your car
or home insurance
they said that americans overspend by a
billions of dollars
on those two items change it up
yup visit the zebra.com t-h-e-o that's
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash theo for insurance in
black
and white yeah you gotta get insured and
be insured well don't get no nasty
insurance
you know sometimes you get that nasty
insurance like you'll call if you get
nasty medical
hey this nasty medical how can we help
you're like oh
my god i fell off the roof man my neck
you know
my my leg is stuck in my my neck
like i we send out all right we're
saying we're sending somebody over man
we'll send clarence over here like clown
what clarence what
and then clarence shows up man he's in a
ford f-250 bruh
and he got speakers in that [ __ ] and
you he can't even lift you he real small
you know he played point guard bro
but only in jv he real small he can't
even lift your body and you got a bad
leg your legs stuck in your neck
you got our neck leg you got
neck leg baby
and so damn bro now you gotta [ __ ]
jump up in the back of the truck on your
one good leg and he rides you over there
and he's playing 50 cent the whole time
get him up
get him up but all the
is going down and you're in the back
like oh
damn you bleeding out back there
go shorty it's your birth and you
bleeding out
they got blood dripping out the back of
the truck
and little clarence trying to get to the
hospital bro but he had to stop for gas
dawg
don't end up with nasty medical
get the good stuff that's all i'm
telling you
speaking of the good stuff man you need
fabulous bro
bit of hypnolitic
you know there's a lot of different uh
opportunities for men to wear clothing
and unfortunately men have always worn
stuff if you look back through time
even only on the first few pages of the
bible is men naked
and then one of the men kills the other
men
and then at that point they said damn we
got a blouse up
and so what happened was uh clothing
and so what happened was clothing and so
people started getting clothed and now
you got
fabulous man fabulous men
represents for every guy who wants to
look and feel his best without
breaking the bank you can't be spending
thousands on a t-shirt
or thousands on a sneaker or a leg brace
or something if you're handicapped
that's right this means lululemon
quality
for half the price because guys deserve
to
work out in good quality stuff
go to fabletics f-a-b-l-e-t-i-c-s
dot com theo that's right for access to
insane deals
get your first two pairs of shorts
for just 24 when you become a fabletics
men
vip member at checkout become a
fabletics man
vip member at checkout all styles all
colors no exclusions
you talking top quality top of the line
stuff that they would wear in rome and
now it's available to you
the best activewear at the best prices
at least 20
to 50 percent off retail prices every
time
you shop get free shipping on all orders
over 49
dollars that's right go to fabletics
f a b l e t i c s dot com slash s.com
t-h-e-o for access
to an insane deal
um man i just can never decide if i
should wear a hat or not
ever get like that you leave you put the
hat on
you try it you're like oh i feel like i
just
i don't like having the hat on so i'm
gonna try the head off i'm gonna try it
backwards and you're like oh am i too
old to have a head on backwards
you know do i look like i'm
you know trying to sell sports equipment
or what's going on and then you
so you go no hat all right how do i do
no hat
do my hair look okay do i seem decent do
i seem clean i always think that
come on mom would say you look dirty
when i was young you look dirty
all right let's get into a couple of
calls right here that came in
and um as always hotline 985-664-9503
you can submit videos on uh
theovonne.com here we go
scottsdale kentucky man my little
brother he got me turned
on listening to this past weekend
just anything theo bond you know what
i'm saying
well praise god brother and thank you
for uh
for reaching out from uh stockstill
kentucky
and um and i never been over there
but kentucky i used to do steroids and i
know that uh
that sometimes people have done those
also in kentucky let's hear more
but he's got a little problem with
smoking the
devil's lettuce you know i used to be
pretty hardcore on all the dope
and uh trying to get him to quit he's
got a good head on his shoulders
but he just paints it he just can't put
down
the that gum green beans i mean i don't
know
i've told him everything tells him been
his buddy
i don't really know what to do i think
if the theo vaughn
called this little son [ __ ] he says hey
man
put smoking the dope it's killing your
brain cells
he might actually quit i don't well look
man
i'm going to tell you this i appreciate
you i think it's nice that you care
enough about your brother to care about
what he's doing
you know when it's hard at some ages
because some ages people gonna
blow their lungs out or blow their liver
out or bloat a dick out even sometimes
if they'd being nasty or whatever
or they got aids or anything like that
or getting aids
but um
you know i mean
weed is a tough one weed is a tough one
because you know sometimes people just
have to run their course with it
and it's safer it's better than other
drugs
you know it's better than somebody doing
a bunch of heroin or a bunch of um
you know cocaine or crack it's better
than that in the sense that it's
you know they're more calmer and that's
nice
but yeah as sometimes you want to get
them off it sometimes you can lose a
sibling or a friend
and they get real depthed up into the
weed and they like a damn swamp it's
like talking to
they so plan it out you know all they're
doing is just kind of sitting there like
a plant they kind of become what they
smoke
they sit in there and they kind of are
unique but they're really just a [ __ ]
plant
and they want water and then they uh
you know they um
and that's it man they just want some
water because they're so high
so i think here's one thing that i'd use
to help quit i just quit i quit smoking
cigarettes you know about almost a year
ago now
dude actually in april it'll be a year
wow
and the thing that helped me quit
i was in kauai man kauai hawaii
and a man i met a man by a smoothie shop
and he was a shaman
you know he was off work smoothie guy
shaman guy
and next thing you know him him and his
old lady got me back at their joint they
got out of you know kind of a low-key
child care kind of center also but they
smoke they have dmt over there
and they had that five meow dmt
that smoky treat baby that brain
smoothie you know what i'm talking about
that [ __ ] turn your whole life into a
damn skill crane baby in the claw the
lord comes out
and just picks things out of you that he
don't want to be there anymore
and one of the things that
the lord's mighty arm picked right out
of me was my desire to smoke cigarettes
because dmt i find it'll put the wheels
on your wants
sometimes your very core has once inside
of it
it has things it wants to do
and if they just don't they don't have
the wheels it don't have the downhill
they don't have the gradient but that
dmt will get in there and do that dirty
work
you know it'll tickle your sister but
buy her a house you know what i'm saying
it does the things that you can't really
you don't want to do and that's what it
did for me man it got inside of me and
i went from literally each day i'd be in
my head like okay am i gonna and i
wasn't a heavy smoker
but i'd smoke a couple at night
and i had a crutch i would smoke when i
didn't want to
that was it i would smoke when i didn't
want to
and anytime i had a problem or an
uncertainty
or a non-surety
or anything i would just i would go
smoke it became my god in a weird way
when i had a question a worry a thought
a concern
or a positive feeling let's smoke let's
smoke oh let's celebrate let's smoke oh
damn
bummer let's smoke it became where i
went when i had a feeling of any sort
so it was so nice when it disappeared i
mean literally
it just that that that five course meal
baby that five meow
dmt just took it completely out of my
my history
and so that's what i think that that
kind of stuff can do is that uh it's the
librarian
inside of you that we all need
so i don't know if that helps to suggest
your brother smoke dmt to quit smoking
weed but
but also i think he has you have to want
it
that's what i'm saying i think he puts
the wheels on your wants
so if he wants it it can happen if he
don't wants it then
i think it it won't happen it has to be
a want that's been ha
that's been occurring in your background
you know it has to be a want that's just
sitting on the stem of your spine
waiting for
a ride home but you you don't you don't
have the power to make it happen
and that dmt does that dirty work that's
what it does
so i think that um that that's a
possibility but sometimes you got to let
people run their course with drugs
so but i'm sorry i just think i think
overall it's just nice that you care
what's going on with your brother at all
you know
and i think i think things are okay in
moderation if he can handle it
uh but if he wants to quit and he can't
then that's when i think that um that
dmt could be an answer
for and could possibly save y'all's
brothership
so all right we had we had uh we had
this video come in right here
um thank you guys for submitting this
from uh tick tock
let's go my number one requested thing
to cook
catfish coupon i'm hydrated i'm
motivated
let's get it dude okay and here you got
a man this is a real
this is like an indoor outdoor man and
this man is like a chef let's hear more
of this and this guy i see the louisiana
flag in the background
he's a louisiana guy let's hear it again
my number one requested thing to cook
catfish coubion i'm hydrated i'm
motivated
let's get it dude we got a half a cup of
butter
half a cup of flour we're making a blind
colored root let's get it dude
holy trinity and some garlic you got
your onions sweating down
you're here with your vegetable juice
and your homemade seafood stuff
you got into a rolling ball add your
stewed tomatoes and your tomato paste
bay leaves green olives fresh lemons
add the creole seasoning you like a
little two-step
we let it simmer for 25 minutes and
while we wait
we hydrate that's alcoholic parsley
green onions
pull out your lemons your bay leaves and
lay down your beautiful louisiana blue
cat
at this point don't stir just sink them
down
yeah you can't see the video but he's
literally pushing pieces of blue cat
down into the um
into the sauce with a boat or
amen catfish could be on a cracker
that's money dude
there you go and so this is a man this
is a louisiana type man
you see something this dude got an eight
ball of lorry seasoning in his pocket
bro you know what i'm saying
this dude this dude will boil your
sister's tits right here
this dude will straight up boil your
sister's tits man he's about that life
bruh
he's about that fire that [ __ ] uh tit
right off the bone life dog that's who
he is bro
this is the kind of dude he'll invite
you over for a hot tub you realize you
in the hot tub next thing you know what
onion goes by
a lemon or artichoke goes by and you
realize you about to be lunch boy
you know i'm saying this dude has
alternate plans
uh what i love about this guy he's one
of those type of guys you see in
louisiana he's v he's
every neighborhood has this guy and you
need this guy this dude is the chef
by the week he works at the chase bank
or he works over there at whitney bank
or reggione's bank or whatever but on
suddenly the weekend hits
and he's dude you know what i'm saying
he's [ __ ] he got the bunsen burner
and he's grilling uh
you know he'll have a damn uh a
cigarette lighter and be
cooking up a piece of damn crab meat
with it you know
they get wild like that guys like this
and if you notice he uses all the vowels
in louisiana they got a lot of extra
vowels
you know you got a e i o u
e r
[Music]
yeah this the kind of dude asked for a
spice rack and a divorce settlement kind
of guy
you know this guy this the kind of guy
he only have one
uh hand because he probably was doing a
boil one time and he dropped one of his
um
he dropped his car keys in at a boil and
he reached in for him on accident
reflexing
he did a you know he just had a
reflection and
now he only got one hand but it still
works so he's you know
he's thankful to god brian all the swamp
gods so
yeah man this is a good talk thanks for
sending this in uh
and i will say this the food looks
absolutely amazing
and i would try i i might have to try
this
dustin uh poirier this looked like
somebody
this guy looked like he's probably in
dustin poirier's family or from his
neighborhood
and i would guarantee that so that's a
little bit of louisiana fire right there
all right let's take another call that
came in right here man as always
985-664-9503
hey theo this is chad from chicago
hey man listen i'm sitting here driving
home from work
and i'm trying to figure out the answer
to this question somebody asked me
and they asked me do you think you own
the clothes
that you're gonna die in not the clothes
that you're gonna be buried in the ones
where
when the when the grizzly bear eats you
what clothes are you wearing
and uh i don't know i don't know if i
if i do or i don't know if i want to
know if i do
uh but i'd love to hear your thoughts i
mean i don't wear a lot of clothes
anyway okay well the end part that's
really
that's getting personal i think brother
but
well let me think do you
that's a good question what clothes you
want to you know
head on out in what's that last
hero for you for your body
you know when do you get you know
because you got to give up the cage
sometimes
i realized more and more recently that
i'm a bird in a cage man
despite all my rage bro i am still just
a rat in a cage actually that's what the
man said but
um i realized that my body is just a
thing that i'm in
i'm i'm in my head i'm
looking out of my eyes that's where my
spirit is i'm
you know my body is just this kind of
like
it has this color and texture and vibe
to it and
you know i got the rib cage of a damn
large cat really but
you know this is who i am but um
will i have the clothes that i want to
die in
i don't you know with
it's tough that's yeah cause who you
know they show up they see oh he died in
that
yeah i guess i would you know i have
green eyes i guess i would like to have
like a green shirt on maybe or something
that's blue or gray but
um i don't want to have like somebody
like a
you know like a darren sharp or jersey
or a marshon lattimore jersey on
i guess in chicago maybe it's probably
kind of cool if you die in like an urlak
or jersey that might be kind of cool
um so yeah i get i don't know it's tough
it's tough to know what's the best thing
to die in and if i own those clothes
already
i guess you have to think of what when
you're gonna die when is your year
you know i don't i go through phases i
go through phases where i feel like i'm
going to be really old and then i go
through a phase where i'm like oh man
you know i hope there's you know is this
thing ever going to show up you know
what i'm saying like when i hear the
doorbell i'm like oh maybe it's the
grim reaper uh so yeah that's a good
question man do i have those clothes
i i i you know what i think i do
because i i don't wear a lot of
different stuff i'm pretty minimal when
it comes to that
you know i'm not like brennan schaub he
has to get like a new
you know a [ __ ] new bat skin hat
every time he goes to
um toledo or something so i don't i
don't need all that
i'm a little bit more simplistic uh so i
bet i probably do have it man but thank
you for asking
and making sure i'm okay and if i have
enough stuff to die in
um let's take another call that came in
man
and you know what actually all right we
got a single mom submission right here
uh that came in somebody uh came and
somebody recommended this beautiful lady
uh and let's see this video gang
hey this is travis from the bay area
i just want to uh nominate my friend
krista
and her three little hellion kids for
the single moms
um she's a badass okay sorry it's loud
out here building a bridge
oh damn and it's a bridge worker if you
can't see the video this man working
bridge right here
and a bridge is just a road that's
[ __ ] brave as [ __ ]
dog if i'm honest with you
other roads look at a bridge and be like
damn
i bet he gets all the britches
you get it bridge [ __ ] um
but yeah man a bridge is just really
it's a [ __ ] robe with some bald baby
gang let's go um but yeah chris
her three kids she's uh put herself
through school
she's put them through hell's sports and
uh she does it all on her own so
if you can at least give her a shout out
or anything uh that'd be awesome
um gang gang theo von you're the man
dude uh watch your show every week
thanks oh thank you and later
thanks bro well it's nice you to be
thinking about somebody else today man i
appreciate that out of you
and um and thanks yeah let's see if we
can't call christ up and see what's
going on
um okay yeah let's do it
yeah yeah oh what's up krista
can you hear me yeah okay hold on one
second i can't hear you i'm not like a
pervert or anything i just
um this isn't like chat roulette or
anything i'm just trying to say hey to
you
now i can hear you can you hear me yes
okay how are you today
i am doing well how are you good i don't
want to let you know i'm not like a
weirdo i'm not with the government or
anything but um
i was just calling you because
they had a fella uh this guy
hey this is travis a guy named travis do
you know him
yeah i do know him he's a white guy he
works on a bridge
yeah well he um
i work on a podcast my name is theo and
i work on a podcast
and he said we do a thing sometimes
where we where we reach out and do
something nice for single moms and he
said oh well i know this lady she's a
single mom and she works really hard and
she has
um you know three great kids and um i
was raised by a single mom so
um yeah every now and th now and then we
just try and like
uh just give back to the community so we
just wanted to give you a thousand bucks
to go do something fun with your kiddos
yeah i'm totally serious so
we just thought it would be it's just
nice that he thought of you actually you
could tell he must think pretty highly
of you
so my god thank you so much
oh you're really welcome um what do your
kiddos like to do what kind of kids you
got anyway men or women
i got two boys and a little girl
okay you got two boys and a girl yeah
oh that's nice what ages are they nine
seven and five
oh dang yes
oh my god i can't believe you're even
alive then
yeah that's a lot of pressure yeah my my
siblings we were all two years apart
um so it's like fight club some days
yeah
i bet it is like fight club we should
start recording it
oh especially at bedtime that's funny
where do you work out are you working
today you off today i
am working today i work at um gi
consultants in reno
oh you all live in reno yes oh yeah
boy i've been over to reno reno's a lot
of aaa meetings a lot of people donating
blood baby let's go
yeah dude i've been to some meetings
over in reno boy
that's a wild place so um have y'all
lived there y'all's whole life
no we just moved here i moved here with
the kids about a year and a half ago
so i just totally relocated us because
it was getting way too expensive where
we were in santa cruz
oh yeah it gets kind of pricey out there
huh yeah so i just relocated us
on a hope that everything was going to
work out
dang and how do you know travis how do
you know him
travis and i have known each other for
let's see maybe like
eight years yeah we used to
get in trouble together and now we don't
yeah
i think he's always he's always been one
of my best friends
yeah yeah oh that's cool yeah you could
tell he thinks he must think pretty
highly of you um
it was just sweet um he he he he's
sending a nice little video so you'll be
able to see it if
i if he shares this with you one day but
um
yeah but we don't want to take up a
bunch of your time we just thought that
uh it was just really nice of him
and um yeah i just remember when i was
young if somebody would have reached out
to my mom and just done something
just a little extra sometime just just
maybe take the edge off for a week you
know
yeah yeah cool
oh so amazing well look give travis a
hug for us when you see him and uh
and um yeah what you gonna go do go do
something fun with the kiddos what do
they like to do
so my little girl likes to do a little
really anything and
everything but the boys are getting real
into baseball so
i'm gonna see maybe i can find them some
basebally to do
or outdoors we're starting to get some
nice weather
yeah that's fun do they play in any of
those little leagues yet or no
no well my son does junior my older ones
done junior giants because it's the free
one
oh yeah so i've had him doing that
because i'm like well i'm not gonna pay
a bunch of money if you're not into it
i'd rather you not be into it if it's
free
yeah we check out yeah yeah oh nice
yeah those organized sports i think is
fun i think kids really dig that you
know
yeah they're doing really good they are
yeah
yeah my middle one just decided to take
a break from gymnastics
which thank god it's expensive so he's
tr
he's he's thinking about his life he
said to decide what he wants to do oh
damn that must be nice i was like damn
you're seven
what do you have going on well i don't
know but
i'm 41 and he and i apparently have the
same thing going on so
i can totally relate to that young fella
i'm like you're going to be doing
that for a long time buddy curricular
activity that's all i need you to do
what do you feel like doing you want to
kick a ball do you want to hit a ball
what do you want to do
yeah i think the less thinking about it
he can do and just the more doing it the
better off he'll be
probably right right um
well uh thanks so much for answering our
call today and uh
yeah my producer nick will follow up
with you and you look lovely and it's
nice to see you today
oh thank you and um and and uh yeah tell
uh tell travis we said hey when you see
him
i will i will okay where's the take care
have a good day
you too thank you so much oh yeah you're
so welcome y'all have fun
hey send us a picture if you do
something fun with the kiddo send us a
picture no pedo
we ain't pedophiles or nothing with us
regular people perfect i totally will
okay cool totally will okay thank you
have a good day thank you have a good
day
okay bye-bye bye yeah she seemed like a
sweet lady man
yeah i think just a little moment of
reprieve for somebody
you know a moment of reprieve for her to
just be able to think
you know just to be able to love your
kids without that extra stress
of and i
i'm not saying we're doing a ton we're
not changing anybody's life
but just have a moment man
i don't think when i was a kid if some
man would have come by or a woman
anybody
and i'm sure people do look the the
government does it
you know you can get help and get
assistance and
we got all of that growing up and man it
just makes me feel
you know it makes me feel
grateful for time really that time gives
you the opportunity to go back and kind
of see what's going on
so um
yeah time gives you the opportunity to
kind of go back and uh
you know just sew up little tears in
your own story
by using the thread of um
of each other you know in a weird way
and maybe that's selfish to think of it
that way it's not selfish but maybe you
know
everything's selfish in a way but it's
just
you know i don't know it just makes me
feel nice that uh
that you know there'll be a little extra
opportunity for them to do something fun
together as a family
um and thank you guys for supporting
this past weekend
let's get another call that came in
right here man um
and uh what do we got here
hey theo it's uh mike ambrose calling
from
london ontario uh big mike out of canada
dog
and i don't know what y'all are doing up
there but
[ __ ] if it gets weirder down here bro i
might come up there and join you fam
let's go pop pop gang
up here in canada i just love listening
your podcast man you do a great job
i mean a lot of emotions every single
episode and you know who doesn't love
that
uh just you know kind of you know maybe
some tip you could help me out with
uh been uh semi uh
professional baseball player for about
you know
four or five years now oh yeah and i
know what you're saying you mean doing
drugs baby
i feel you baby i used to say stuff like
that i want my semi-pro ball player
people are like oh you're doing drugs so
but go on brother i feel you um before
that you know went to college did the
whole thing
um especially being from canada it was
tough
you know going over the states to play
ball i lived in australia for two years
time of my life but now you know oh yeah
and lived in australia is obviously
another term for doing drugs
um so i feel you baby the code language
daddy
you know what i'm saying uh
spending time at grandma's house i know
what you're saying baby let's hear it
i just this past december on
the 12th had a beautiful baby girl okay
you got that offspring now baby
you got that offspring now you got
something to worry about now you got a
real rock to smoke daddy let's hear it
and uh she's been you know absolutely
amazing but i think it's time to
you know now you know turn the page and
start that family life i just wanted to
know uh
your thoughts you think i should just
keep it keep it buzzing or should i uh
you know sting it and hang out with the
two ladies of my life uh
keep it buzzing what are you talking
about son
okay you live in canada brother
it ain't but you know what i'm saying
the buzzing
it ain't that insane you know what i'm
saying
what i mean you know as crazy as it gets
is kind of ice cream you know what i'm
saying like let's don't be
uh you can't keep it what are you gonna
do you have a child now
what do you mean you're gonna keep it
buzzing what are you gonna do
you're gonna keep playing pro ball daddy
you're gonna keep smoking rock
huh you're gonna keep using
you're gonna take care of your wife and
kid man
if it's your wife i don't know you
didn't say he wasn't married up or you
guys
it was nuptialed up you know
and maybe the dope haze has been too
heavy in your daddy
but i believe that it's time yeah if you
got something living that came out of
your wiener you got to take
you got to take care of it baby you know
and i love you mike and i feel like
you know i don't want to be the one to
you know
serve you the cold [ __ ] baby
you know but consider me that freaking
um that matrix dick
you know what i'm saying i'm that head
waiter baby and i'm serving you that
cold [ __ ] a truth dog
and the truth is yeah there's no
you know you gotta you gotta settle you
gotta tighten it up
you can't be sleeping in your car doing
canadian drugs
even though they're cheaper um
you know when you get them direct you
know we don't have to go through a big
pharma but
anyway man um yeah i wish you the best
of luck brother i really do
and i hope you definitely you know you
get it figured out up there praise god
baby
okay let's take another call here here
we go
hey theo this is scott again from
tennessee
what's up scott and um
thank you for calling brother from
tennessee man
and that is a unique state it's a very
long state
it's basically that sideways florida
baby let's hear it
and i'm out here in virginia okay so now
you move to somewhere
okay all right scott working on the
storm crew
you know taking care of all these
hangers and all these dangerous limbs
after storms
okay so you out there on that limb track
and you out there checking lean wood
baby i feel you
and reaching for lean wood baby gang
and i just wanted to call and ask
about how i could help my girlfriend
trust me more while i'm out here we have
a lot of issues with that she always
thinks i'm not drinking with the guys
when i'm really just at the hotel
and i just wanted to ask what you
thought i could do
to make her feel better without audrey
thank you very much gang gang
gang baby and thank you for reaching out
man
and look we all know you're out drinking
with the guys scotty and that's fine
nobody's you know
nobody's mad at you or anything like
that but yeah you got to make sure that
your wife is
content because they will steal stuff
while you're gone and they will
a lot of them will even do arson now
there's a lot of mexican women and a lot
of women in um
um new mexico
doing arson and anyway
the bottom line here i'm seeing is um
i mean first of all if you're in a tree
every day and you out there
hunting uh limbs and stuff chisel a
little note to the la you know
scotty loves you know teresa or whatever
scotty loves dying and put it in the
wood man chisel it in there
leave that advertisement out there snap
her a photo send her that
say here i just chiseled this into the
side of a you know
a birch out here
outside of a roanoke or whatever
or virginia beach baby you know what i'm
saying you could do stuff like that
when you get back to the hotel center
that picture right here i am right here
about an ice maker about a hampton inn
baby i'm chill
and so is this machine you know cute
little things like that
but yeah some of it it's interesting
sometimes we'll use jealousy also to
express that we care it could just be
her saying look i care but i'm afraid to
just say it like that instead i do
jealousy
or i do you know trust you know they
don't
they don't trust you
but it's hard man getting somebody's
trust
you know i've never been real good at it
man
you know sometimes i think i don't know
if i want people to trust me in a weird
way
because trust you have to have a trust
means there's a connection
trust means trust is
there's responsibility
you know trust is just that damn
condiment
you know on that responsibility bun baby
and so yeah if you got trust with
somebody you're going to be that's a
lifetime
you know it's a that's an ongoing
commitment that we're going to behave a
certain way and we're going to
communicate a certain way and honor each
other's time and
damn it sounds like a lot
but i think an easy way to see if you
could start man if you're real serious
about it
i've had times in my life i wasn't even
real i would get a girl to trust me but
at the same time be
doing untrustful stuff
being trustful untrustful
um
so it's tough man but i think yeah
chisel or some [ __ ]
into the tree you know tommy loves robin
or whatever
you know scotty loves vivian you know do
something nice do some cute little
things like that
i think that could definitely help or
get one of those big johnson t-shirts
remember them go look at them on ebay's
big johnson they got some cute stuff
they make
um and let's take one more call that
came in man
here we go 985-664-9503
and i'm gonna let you know also that uh
the last website i've ever needed
is now theovonne.com and that was made
by a company
called modify
they do great business websites and they
have a new program called the last
website
you will ever need no cost to build
no contract 45-day turnaround
unlimited revisions and support easy
editing tools
free redesign satisfaction guaranteed
it's all for just 249 dollars a month
wow
that's a good deal the last website
you'll ever
need visit modifymodiphy.com
theo and get a 250 credit
when you subscribe for your world-class
website again that's modify
with a p-h-m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com slash
t-h-e-o
support small businesses that do a big
job they've done great for us modify.com
theo
let's hit this hot
line right here here we go
what's up theo i uh i'm from north
carolina
16 years old and uh
this morning i just got the news that my
grandpa passed away
oh man i'm sorry bro
i'm sorry about that yeah 16 a lot of
people
you know grandparents are really
i mean they're the damn hamsters of the
uh
you know of the family in a lot of ways
they
they'll kind of go out on you let's hear
it
and it was really really strange because
i mean just a week ago you know i was
sitting on his couch
you know talking to him but i mean it's
just so sudden
that i mean i really don't even believe
it i mean i haven't even cried or
you know been angry or anything i just
like i can't believe it
but uh yeah i just want to know how you
deal with
you know death that are just kind of
unexpected and
you know come out of nowhere
well you know thanks for the call man
and death
death is all
it's like hot it's like there's this
force playing hide and go
seek or playing freeze tag and you
didn't even know you're in it you forget
you're playing this game
of freeze tag with time
and man when it touches you that's
it must be so just to people who when
you get to
that's how it is you know it's like oh
okay
that's my turn uh all right wow
okay i got it this no more i gotta
and you don't get to pack your things
that's gotta be a wild part
i bet when people first say hey you know
if doctor tells you
you know it's your time it's your turn i
bet i go home and start to pack
just out of habit
you know i'm used to going somewhere or
being somewhere
but uh
but yeah now it's like you get
you get that call and there's nothing to
pack all you can do is kind of pack
almost as unpacking
you know hopefully you have enough time
to unpack your [ __ ]
to unpack a you know a couple bags of
forgiveness
unpack a few apologies unpack all the
the fire you've been holding
you gotta unpack it some
you know i don't i was at a my
grandparents didn't really
i don't know my grandmother
wasn't super keen on me and so i didn't
have much of a relationship with her as
i got
into my teens and stuff and
but i've always had a strong affinity
for seniors you know my father was a
senior
and um and so i've always had a
you know a warm place in my heart for
him and it's interesting that
a lot of older people they kind of
i feel like a little bit they're ready
to go
because after you've done it all after
you've had all the tiramisu you've
wanted and
you've traveled to the places you wanted
to go or were
brave enough to take on the adventures
you could take on
your shell your body starts to die so
really do you just this
you're almost like when you whenever you
see a firefly inside of a little
lantern or something or like tinkerbell
on
peter pan's when you see it
the cage the cage dies man
but that hitter baby is that that tanker
dog
that's the part that zips off to
somewhere else
so
your grandpa's probably happy to get out
of that old ass cage i bet
i bet that has to feel pretty freeing
you know almost like the first time you
get to drive a car when you're
you know in louisiana you could drive
when you're 15 when i was child you
could drive 15 years old
some people hadn't even jerked off their
own body and they were driving
which was crazy you'd ask somebody if
they could bust out and they couldn't
but they could
you know do reverse
you know there's different times but um
anyway man i don't know what i'm telling
i don't know exactly what i'm telling
you but
yeah you got that tankers left in the
tank
when the tank rusts so really i bet for
your grandfather it's like him it's like
the first time you got to go down the
road and drive yourself
god there's nothing like that just the
freedom you feel like i'm
free i'm free
i'm away from for that you're away from
your parent the first time you venture
down the street before you get to the
stop sign and you got to turn and make a
decision and [ __ ] it gets scary then but
before that
there's a blood there's a little bit of
space where you're like oh my god
you folks are standing back in the
driveway and they don't know
you know and you're going
he's like wow
i bet that's what it's like man
it's just you know at that point when
you're young you're getting you know
you're shedding that skin of your
parents constant attent you know uh
nesting over you and um you having to
ask them for a ride or having to walk to
work or do the bus
and now suddenly you live in freelance
so i bet that's what it's like your
grandpa
he's probably in that night you know
he's in that 1984
ford escort in the sky
and he's listening to some abbey road by
the beatles or some damn nelly
and he's just feeling good bro he's
living
he's living again so i bet there's some
real
i bet he's off on a ride man
so you know maybe do some [ __ ] to honor
and wish him well maybe
yeah and make the use of the most out of
your cage while you got it
make the most out of your cage while you
got it man
um i think we did pretty good
man i think we did pretty good
you know that's all i got
that's all i got uh
what a great song that we came in on we
got heather mcmahon is going to be in
this week
beautiful comedian out
of uh new york and atlanta
we're trying to think of unique guests
if you think of somebody unique let us
know
thank you so much for supporting this
podcast
you know i'm grateful to have uh the
opportunity to be here with you every
week
and have continued to do this now for a
couple years now
and um and the last year has been really
hard but you guys have really been there
for me and we've been there for each
other bro and that's how we do it here
we do our best i feel like to just kind
of keep it going
so i don't think we should stop that you
know
i want to wish everyone a happy early
easter um
you know it's a nice time it's really
usually a beautiful time of year i hope
that springtime is starting to hit
everyone
i remember going into our easter party
one time they had this lady
that lived by us and she was doing she
was female pedophile actually but the
guys she was seeing were 16 years old
and they were big men they were really
i mean just bigger than regular men i'd
seen these men were these boys were big
and
she would invite them over to do
learning and stuff
or spelling and they would just do sex
or really drink
or they would spell words like [ __ ]
and um they had an easter party one time
and i wandered in there i was a kid
and i'd sneak over there sometimes and
get that
while they're all smoking cigarettes i'd
get as much cigarette smoke as i could
into my mouth and [ __ ]
and just [ __ ] feel alive bruh
god it made me feel alive and one time i
sprayed mason there i didn't know
what was going on exactly but i sprayed
a little bit of mace in the air at the
dance party when they were dancing and
you know if maybe 50 seconds later a
minute and 10 seconds later
people crying and pouring milk in their
eyes one guy kept pouring milk in his
eyes i remember
and uh
you know it's just i don't know it's a
holiday time man i'm excited i'm hoping
to go to baton rouge louisiana and see
my family
and i hope some of you guys get to spend
time with your loved ones
um i'm off jiu jitsu right now for
another week
my ribs heal up i think i have a
fractured rib
uh so i'm just trying to make the most
of the time the down time that i have
um and that's all that's going on with
me thank you guys for the calls let me
know what's going on with you
thanks for the suggestions for the um
quote for the man
and uh thank you guys for patreon for
supporting this past weekend
and uh and you guys be good to yourself
man
you guys deserve it
this is the come up with eddie 9v
and we'll put that video montage at the
very end guys
[Music]
again
um
[Music]
well
well i just got home and now i'm back i
got so many people asking where i'm at
i've been to tennessee
and ohio so
women know i'm on a camera
[Music]
nothing really much
well if you're asking me what i really
wanna do is just come right back make
love to you i'm gonna come up
come on eddie
[Music]
and right there that's uh they come up
with eddie 9v you guys be good to
yourselves man
y'all deserve it thank you
what's up theo it's jack in indiana here
we got a young man who uh
needs a little help on his senior quote
for his yearbook
uh i'ma let him i'm letting plagiarize
mine real quick so
my little advice to you if you're gonna
do a senior quote is uh just
keep it short and simple but keep it
slick you know you want something to
make the girls in 10 years be like damn
i wonder what he's up to nowadays man
he's kind of slick you know
so just keep it short and simple give a
little something like i'm the man of the
hour
too sweet to be sour gang hi my name is
kevin i'm from toronto ontario i have
two suggestions my first is from eutheo
which is um an event is like regular
time only more special which i think is
fairly profound and then
my second is one that i used when i was
in my senior year and that's
andrew santino is a stupid ugly ginger
gang gang
what's going on theo my name's alex i'm
from st
louis missouri i got a suggestion for
zachary's
yearbook quote i think it should be the
classic
goodfellas all my life
growing up i always wanted to be a
gangster
i think that would be pretty cool to put
in the yearbook
uh hope this makes it on the show thanks
man
what up theo this is ryan minneapolis
mantis baby
uh listen to your episode today
uh about the guy called up about the
yearbook quote my yearbook quote
was of all my friends i am the leader
and a lot of my friends didn't
appreciate that [ __ ] and
uh it didn't go well but i still think
it's funny
i i still get a kick out of that and i'm
i'm still glad i did it so
to that young buck out there looking for
a quote
do something that uh you know you're
gonna
you're gonna find uh entertaining or
or funny or whatever in the future and
don't worry about your friends because
chances are you're not gonna have those
friends
uh you know 20 years from now whatever
all right
that's it thanks to you love you book